hi everyone welcome to the homeroom
livestream today we're actually just
going to have an ask me anything so any
questions you have for me about anything
I encourage you to put below whether
you're watching this on Facebook or
YouTube put this on the the message
boards below and we a few members will
look at it and surface questions about
anything so please start doing that and
now that I've given you a head start on
asking questions I will give my standard
announcements we are not-for-profit
the others are why Khan Academy can even
exist is because with philanthropic
donations from folks like yourself so if
you're in a position to do so please
think about donating to Khan Academy I
do want to give a special shout out to
several corporations that stepped up
especially as they saw that we were
already running at a deficit freak ovid
and then with kovat our server cost went
up we were trying to accelerate a whole
series of programs so special thanks to
Bank of America google.org 18g fastly
and Novartis and that health has been a
big deal but we are still running at a
deficit and so any support whether
you're a corporation or you're just an
individual at any amount makes a huge
difference it allows us to reach a lot
more folks another series of
announcements I will introduce my
colleague Dan that some of y'all have
seen before on the livestream Dan has
some announcements as well hi everyone I
think so so we have a couple of
announcements and reminders for everyone
for this week so today we just full list
we recognize that summer is different
from the regular school year so we
created a playlist of recommended
activities covering math language arts
and creativity and in the math section I
just want to call out two things first
camp Khan as well as get ready for grade
level courses so as a reminder that we
launched to get ready for grade level
courses this week and each of those math
courses will contain the most important
prerequisite skills for that particular
grade and we know you have a limited
amount of time so the intent is really
to provide learners with the most
efficient way to engage with their
upcoming grade level work and wrapping
the get ready for grade level courses is
camp Khan so camp Khan launched this
Monday as a reminder it's our virtual
summer camp that kicked off and it will
run through the end of August camp Khan
helps students prepare for math in the
fall with those get ready for grade
level courses
and camp Khan was designed to build
habits and mindsets for learning and
we're really intentional about making it
fun for the summer and so if you want to
learn more there's a parent webinar all
about camp Khan tomorrow at 4 o clock to
4:30 PST 7 o'clock Eastern Time so
please join us if you want to learn more
so those are the announcements for this
week thanks al great thanks Dan
and I'll just doubly underline some of
what Dan just mentioned obviously we had
Lindsay on on Monday talking about to
get ready for grade level courses we're
really excited about this because in any
summer a lot of students need you know
have gaps or they need to fill in to be
ready and this is going to be a summer
an extended summer where many many more
students are going to need that help and
so whether you're student a parent or
teacher this is a great way for students
to get ready for grade-level work and
and make sure they have no swiss-cheese
gaps going into it and then camp Khan as
Dan just mentioned is a great way of
making it even more interactive and fun
and having a whole layer of programs and
fun on top of they get ready for grade
level courses so definitely check check
those things out so with that I'm happy
to take some questions what six
questions have already come in let's see
from YouTube IAA says hi Sal do you know
how schools expect to open with Cova 19
if they do how will they do it safely
and if they don't how can they make sure
we're learning thank you well aya a I
think what you're referring to is a you
know I think we talk to a lot of
district superintendents and principals
and teachers and I think everyone is
really struggling with it because I
think even two weeks ago before Kovan 19
started to pick up again and it does
look like it's picking up again and much
of the u.s. at least people were
thinking that all right we're going to
do some type of socially distant shift
based model for back-to-school where
half the kids come on say Monday and to
Monday and Wednesday and the other half
come on Tuesday and Thursday or or maybe
the high school students don't come to
school and do everything virtually and
then they use that real estate for the
middle of elementary school so that
people can become more socially distance
also do shift based with the teacher so
this is really complex thing that people
were thinking about it even before the
pickup and kovat people were also
expecting a potential pickup and cove
aid so you
I have to virtualize really fast or go
to hybrid learning or even if you are
able to show up there might be a subset
of kids whose families don't feel
comfortable sending them to school so
you're gonna have to have some virtual
model my what I'm hearing right now and
this is you know a few days old it might
change based on based on you know the
epidemiological statistics of how a
barkovis spread is people are definitely
focused on the younger students because
I think that's where frankly the child
care issues super difficult for a lot of
families I think in areas where they can
people are thinking very seriously about
outdoors we had Rachel skipper on
yesterday from Kahn Lab school and I and
her have been talking a lot about how
can we leverage you know cordon off some
of the parking lot and essentially you
know have some hotspots and leverage
that for outdoor play or even getting
work done for at least part of the day
to make it a little bit more safer and
to get some social distancing but the
simple answer is I think people are
still struggling with what can you do
even from a physical spacing
epidemiological point of view and then
once you get that right given how
uncertain did is the curricular point of
view is even more uncertain this is
where Khan Academy we are trying our
best to help support schools teachers
parents and students as you know Dan's
announcement about the get ready for
grade level course that part of it to
make sure that people are what if they
can use this over the summer that's
great they'll be more ready for back to
school but even if they don't use this
over the summer either the first couple
of weeks of back to school could be
focused on that get ready for grade
level because a lot of kids have been
disengaged for many months now or as you
go through the grade level work you can
in parallel do the get ready for grade
level we're also working on learning
plans some of you all know several
months ago we had learning plans for
learning especially math through the end
of the school year in the summer and now
we want to create learning plans for
starting back to school through the
school year so expect to see those in
the next few weeks and we are actually
working on a study of what were the best
practices of schools during or districts
during school closures and given the
best practices before
what are at play books for districts and
schools to think about hybrid learning
where you're doing some
in Kahn Academy where kids are learning
at their own time and pace but you're
also leveraging synchronous sessions
whether it's socially distanced inside
the classroom or synchronous sessions on
videoconferencing of some how and how
can you do that well what are the best
practices so we're going to try our best
to support teachers and districts in
this situation but the simple answer is
I think very few people really know how
this is how this is going to evolve and
it's a little scary because we're only
about eight weeks away and obviously if
Kovac keeps picking up we might be back
into a lockdown scenario in a couple of
weeks that isn't that different than
what we saw in March and April and May
so what we're trying to do the most on
our side to help out but it's going to
be going to be tough and uncertain for a
lot of folks so let's see from YouTube
osama al-safi says Sal do you have any
plans on improving your site and making
new versions of videos with better
quality making you techniques for
teaching or making online paid courses
for example using zoom good question so
the simple answer is yes we're
constantly trying to think about how to
improve the site and Khan Academy you
know we're over 200 folks and I know
somebody wants a 200 folks you know
that's a lot we can do a lot with that
but I remind folks you know we're the
budget of a large high school and we're
trying to we have 107 million registered
users and we have you know 80 90 million
minutes of learning per day during the
school year during weekdays so we're
trying to allow we cover some you know
we have Khan Academy kids at the pre-k
level which covers math reading writing
social-emotional learning and then math
obviously we keep going all the way to
early college then you know we have the
sciences at the high school and early
college level we're adding English
language arts we have test prep so
there's a lot of dimensions that we're
working on but the but we have a steady
pipeline of improvement some of them
aren't as obvious you know we're doing a
major infrastructure rehaul right now
which won't change your user experience
other than it will hopefully make the
site faster for you and more performance
and more reliable for you and that also
it will make it easier for us to develop
new features now in the future side
we're constantly thinking about how do
we change the user experience so that it
is more engaging so that is more
infected and more effective and so you
asked a lot about video so we're you
know
I have a list of videos that I'm either
redoing or new videos to cover certain
topics or it seems like we still have
gaps we have a whole content team that's
constantly adding and revising exercises
and we have a large engineering and
product team designers product managers
to think about both of the back end how
do we make the infrastructure more
scalable as we're trying to serve so
many people and the front end which in
kind of you know tech speak is the user
experience side of things how do we make
it more engaging and so you know you're
see things like this get ready for grade
level courses that's where on the
content side we're doing these learning
plans that's kind of on the content
school partnership side of things and
for this back to school we're going to
have things you know we're going to
bring back certain reports the teachers
have been asking or improve those
reports and then I hope a few months
after that you'll start seeing some
navigational improvements on the side so
there's a lot that we're trying to
juggle right now that was and I just
kind of glazed over the the tip of the
iceberg of what's going on so this is so
Facebook Carol Smith capper says Sal do
you have any recommendation for older
students who are supposed to be spending
the summer doing internships so they
have all been canceled uh I do have
advice and I don't know how good it is
so you know take it or leave it so to
speak but I suppose I've been telling
the stand a young person who in that
situation I think there's a ton of
opportunity right now to do really
interesting things that can help a lot
of folks there could be simple things of
supporting people who live alone
especially elderly people who or might
be feeling very isolated right now in
times of kovat and you know helping them
get tech access or through tech access
you know making sure that they have
someone to talk to have someone to help
them out with the groceries and you know
you it would be for you to figure out
how to do that in kind of a safe
socially distance way I think there's a
lot of potentially educators teachers
who could help using support especially
as they're trying to transition to this
hybrid model and teach kids over zoom or
whatever else maybe you could be a
teaching assistant for them and some
works we have this project schoolhouse
dot world that this is not a Khan
Academy project it's more of a South
project maybe one day it'll become part
of a Khan Academy project but it is this
notion that on Khan Academy you can
learn at your own time pace get practice
feedback game mechanics teachers can
monitor it there's videos and articles
to help unstick you and hints on each of
the exercises but a complete learning
experience would also involve some form
of synchronous live human interaction
where you can ask questions where you
can ask questions not only just from a
teacher or tutor but maybe also from
peers and so this notion about
schoolhouse dog world which is mariahs
and is a volunteer who's been driving
this and I've one of my buddies from
colleges named shishir maroa is a runs a
company called coda at i/o they've
essentially volunteered their time to
build the schoolhouse dog world so that
it can match tutors and students who
need help so that you know you can
volunteer to be a tutor but
interestingly right now we have a you
know the social engineering experiment
that we're doing right now we have more
tutors and less demand so if anyone has
questions and especially high school
math go to school house that world right
now there's a little registration form
and then we we let people in so we're at
this unusual situation right now where
there's a lot of amazing people who are
hungry to tutor people for free as
volunteers and we're looking for more
students who need that tutoring so
definitely go to school hostile world
whether you want to be a tutor or
whether you want to learn something I
could imagine you know there's a bunch
of other you know it might not even be
related to Cove it right now but you
know you could this is a great time on
on Boone to start a podcast or an
interview series on a topic that you
find interesting and you know a lot of
folks are have more time on their hands
right now because they're at home and
they're not traveling and all of that so
you'd be surprised you could reach out
to folks and have interesting
conversations with them III think it's
interesting this is a family project you
know get on zoom' with family members
all over the country or the world and
record your family history you know
that's not going to be the type of
internship that's going to pay you but I
actually think it's pretty cool just to
have yet you know if you think about if
your house is burning down god forbid
you don't you know you know the thing
that you're going to try to
to leave the house with all your
pictures and all your family memories
and you know one thing that I've been
trying to do is videotape family members
especially older family members and you
know ask them about their life history
ask them about their childhood ask them
about their journeys of life the
struggles I get them on video you know
you can record zoom and Google Hangouts
and all that so I think that could also
be another interesting project but
there's tons of opportunity I think to
focus on whatever topic is interesting
to you so the admin [ __ ] Walla says the
sir you make all the subjects very
interesting thanks odd not I I
appreciate that how did you find your
love for a particular subject well if
your question is how do i how do I find
a love for all subjects it's because I
do generally believe all subjects are
interesting you know I've said this
multiple times on the live stream that
it you know sometimes students feel like
oh I got to learn this subject you know
this is I guess I'll do it what's on the
test we have to realize that knowledge
that you get to learn well first of all
it's the luxury if you think about like
human history the luxury to be able to
dedicate years of your life for the
pursuit of learning most of human
history most human being did not have
that luxury and that the learning that
we now have access to we have access to
the the total of human knowledge or most
of it up until this point and you know
many very smart folks would have done
anything to have access to the knowledge
that you now have access to now I do
think sometimes textbooks and some
courses don't do the best job of
reminding folks how exciting this massed
knowledge is and hopefully Khan Academy
at least you know sometimes if I'm
making the video you hear it in my voice
but I'm excited about it or something
interesting here but I would remind
yourself about that in particular you
know if your question is how how how did
I find the path in life like how did I
decide what to focus on given that I
somehow found found every subject
interesting I mean I used to say in
college if there was something called a
PC and everything I would have tried to
get that PhD because I really enjoyed
learning about a lot of very things and
draw to try to draw connections between
them but you know for me it was a
combination I've had a lot of debt my
family
it was not very wealthy so when I was 21
years old I was like okay let me do
something that I find really interesting
but I think you know I've developed some
really good skills at that can also help
pay off debt even help support my family
and so you know this was in I graduated
1998 from college and from a master's
program so I computer science it was a
great time and it frankly is even a
better time now than that in that field
but as I went into that path you know I
actually just gave a few graduation
addresses and what I've told everyone is
when you're young if you can you often
say oh do I pick this major that page do
they pick that job or that job and you
know ask a lot of people make the best
informed decision you can but there's no
such thing as the perfect decision there
there's no such thing as the perfect
path what matters more is the energy and
the attitude that you bring to that path
so whatever it is so I happen my first
job was a product manager at Oracle
which is a big kind of database at a
prize software company and you know my
boss told me looked out you know if you
need to sometimes get cynical at a big
company you feel like you're kind of a
small cog in a big machine he's like
just make every day better than the last
how are you making yourself better how
are you making the people around you
better constantly be asking questions
constantly looking around for
opportunities for you to make a
difference whether it's at work or at
home and then my boss after business
school I worked at a hedge fund so you
can tell I have done my share of career
changes you know he reminded me that
it's super important as an investor to
have time to pursue your passions and
develop interest because it allow you to
see the world in new ways that other
people and participating in the stock
market do not and so you might be able
to see an interesting investment before
others and it also is this a way to
recharge and make sure that you're not
making a bunch of bad decisions but more
likely making a few good decisions so
that's my best advice pick a path ask a
lot of questions and you know you don't
have to be embarrassed about even asking
about very practical things about how
much money do you make what are the work
hours what are the benefits but also is
this going to be a job that I can enjoy
doing but I'm not going to be you know
miserable doing and then once you find
that path make sure you have space for
your passion and then you have this
positive attitude towards both the
Bob and what you're able to do outside
of outside of your work and the last
thing I would say don't define yourself
entirely by your work I think in our
society we kind of define who we are as
people by our work and then that creates
this kind of weird stress and and and
almost equipped based on satisfaction
with work because you're looking for
almost too much meaning out of your work
where you could get a lot of meaning in
other things in life let's see so either
a good question though so Rylan rate
says I've used calculus five years and I
have to say thank you okay thank you
Rylan for thanking us what is going to
be your next update what course are part
of the website are your most proud of
thank you so much well you know as we've
talked about some of the updates things
like to get ready for grade level
courses expect to see things like
learning plan soon we're constantly
iterating and tweaking all of the
content across the site we are there's
going to be some teacher tools that are
going to get updated in the next few
actually in time for back-to-school we
have some plans that are probably about
six months away you know don't don't
hold me to it because there's a lot
going on where we want to improve the
navigation around course mastery and
things like that those are the big ones
I mean there's definitely more subject
areas that we want to improve on so yeah
there's a lot let's see from YouTube
Suhana Anaya says I forget math but
practice before very easily it's hard to
remember again in practice hard to
remember again in practice so what
should I do to never forget them well
Sanne you know my best advice and this
is actually backed up by research
there's this notion of spaced repetition
which Khan Academy tries to do which is
when you learn something there's kind of
a forgetting curve that you know there's
over time your your your your your
likelihood of being able to know it
diminishes over time but if you if after
some degradation you go and review that
thing again your the probability that
you know it gets back to where it was
before and not this time because of that
spaced repetition your degradation curve
is slower and so then after say twice as
long you review it again then your
degradation curve will be even slower so
my best advice to you would be one keep
if you can create a consistent practice
say even 15-20 minutes a day
say three four or five days a week on
Connick um if you can make
to have it just like brushing your teeth
or making your bed which I also highly
recommend that then I think it's much
less likely that these skills will
atrophy and that you will forget so to
speak and we have things like mastery
challenges that make you review things
that you you know do this do that spaced
repetition and we have things like horse
challenges and unit tests the other
thing I would say is when you're
learning especially math you know
sometimes there's this tendency to
memorize formulas and just say okay what
steps do I need to do to get the right
answer that might work in the short term
sometimes and it'll just be and that
will work less and less as you get into
more and more advanced math what's far
more helpful is to think about why does
it work why does it make sense that
algebraic step it's not some magic
incantation why does it make sense that
you have to add the same thing to both
sides of an equation well two things
were equal before if you do something to
only one side of it if you change the
value of only one side they can't be
equal anymore so you have to change the
value in the same way to both sides so
always connect these dots what you'll
find is all of math is connected and if
you do that especially with more of the
foundational skills you're going to find
that the more advanced skills almost
become intuitive you're going to be like
why don't they I mean why does someone
you want to tell me this this is obvious
so I highly recommend do the spaced
repetition and really sit and think and
ponder why something in math make sense
and how it connects to other things you
know and what I just said actually isn't
just math the supplies frankly thought
to almost any field you're trying to
study so let's see rudra no mundial
from facebook says how do you deal with
social media negativity it's a good
question and you know I've said on this
on this forum before that I do things
like meditation and how it's kind of
like rain-x for the for the mind for
your emotions rain-x if you don't know
the thing that you can kind of wipe onto
your windshield and that when it rains
the water just kind of beads up and
washes off you almost don't even need a
windshield wiper if you put that
chemical I don't know if the chemicals
good for you not but it does wonders for
beating up water but I've always said
things like meditation are are kind of
like rain-x for your mind because
obviously if someone says something to
you that you know you disagree with or
says your
like this or is making a generalization
about you or saying something negative
we all have an ego of different sizes
that immediately wants to react to that
that immediate if I can't believe they
said that I can't believe they think
that about me don't they know that I'm
this bad or I'm a good person you know
we all have these internal voices which
is really our ego when you meditate you
realize you are not here you go you are
not that little voice that's always
trying to defend itself and then you can
kind of let these things go a little bit
more it identifies your awareness less
with your persona you're like you know
what they're criticizing this thing that
they perceive called sal or whatever but
i'm not that and really should i get
that much that worked up about it you
know one day the sun will will absorb
the earth and the universal experience
kind of a heat death you know is this
really that big of a deal with that said
you know it does it does hit you every
now and then and you know i'm not you
know i we're lucky at Khan Academy
because we are I believe doing kind of a
positive social thing that most of the
feedback we get is is positive but we do
get we do get critiques and criticisms
and every now and then I get emails at
one of my email addresses at the desk on
email which I to do a look at which are
kind of angry sometimes I think I
suspect maybe a student feels a little
frustrated with the mastery mechanics or
something and they'll sometimes even use
expletives which you I read those things
and then doesn't feel great but I just
remind myself that you know if they're
not really don't it's not really going
at you directly it's going at you know
someone's conception of what they think
is some type of an organization I think
it's much easier for people to be a
little bit mean to what they think is an
abstract organization than you know to
another to another human being but yeah
so bottom line meditate try not to take
that seriously recognize that what folks
say about you on social media or
anywhere else really isn't defining of
who you are let's see
so Michelle Marie Moussaoui says from
Facebook any advice on how to help kids
with math anxiety so I'm not a
psychologist so take what I'm about to
do with a grain of salt but I saw this
even in the early days when I was
tutoring my cousin's the the I think
there's
something very powerful about building a
habit and then as you build a habit and
they work on Khan Academy and you start
building some confidence because you
know over the summer the students able
to work on Khan Academy even 20 minutes
a day there's not the stresses of oh I
have to get this homework done by
tomorrow or how am I going to perform on
the exam where I want to make sure that
I get an A or B in the class
none of those anxieties are there so
it's really you're just doing it the way
that you might you know learn a musical
instrument or practice a sport and so
that I think in of itself starts to
reduce the anxieties and as the students
practice in a kind of a deliberate
habit-forming way that they will gain
more confidence and I recommend using to
get ready for grade level courses or
even start at kids even if they're you
know a later elementary school or middle
school students start them at early
learning or start them in their
arithmetic score in the arithmetic
course so they can review some of those
basics and and build that confidence and
then fill in all their swiss-cheese gaps
which is another source of lack of
confidence so that when they get to
their grade level or beyond they feel a
lot more confident the other thing is
you know I think it's reminding students
just a little bit of that medication
conversation I'd say actually even a
minute or two a meditation which is
really just sitting silently and and and
letting your thoughts get as still as
possible I think is really powerful for
any type of anxiety I've said it on this
form before I've never really enjoyed
planes I get kind of claustrophobic on
planes it's like a real thing for me and
I just remind myself look about you know
that that anxiety circuit in your brain
that's starting to cycle that's not you
and once you can kind of just observe
that it starts to slow down and you're
like hey you know I'm not this thing
that's anxious about this plane and it
is what it is you know the die has been
cast
but it serves no one for me to be
miserable about this and I think even
with young kids when you talk about that
and we talk about things that growth
mindset that look you should it's not
about whether you get it right or get it
wrong it's all about the effort that you
put into it it's not about whether
you're smart or not smart I'd argue
there's not you know that's not the
thing it's about how much are you
willing to persevere and have resiliency
and when you get something wrong learn
from those mistakes and that's actually
where you when your brain grows the most
let's see other other there's a lot of
good questions here so Susana Garcia
Dominguez are one of our regulars on the
live stream good diffuse design
hopefully one day we'll meet in person I
feel like I know you have so many good
question what are some of your favorite
movies and I think I've answered that in
a previous ask me anything I will say
you know we had Francis Ford Coppola on
a couple of about two weeks ago and I'm
not usually a fan of bloody movies and
violent movies I'm actually I'm pretty I
guess you could say soft that way I you
know I'm usually a fan of like Pixar and
things like that but the Godfather is
one of the top movies of all time and so
that's why it was pretty cool to have
Francis on I take Gandhi is definitely
one of my favorite when I was in college
I used to organize an annual viewing of
Gandhi as so that's also one of my top
favorite movies I will say Star Wars you
know Episode four the original one and
you know the newer Star Wars it feels
like it's a little bit of a business now
where they keep kind of going through
the same plotline and so it's kind of I
don't know you know the plotline seems
to be over and over you know someone who
used to discover their potential and
struggle with the dark force while the
Empire's building some device that can
peel planets you know I think they're
reusing that plot a little bit too much
so the new Star Wars in some ways kind
of I don't know making the original Star
Wars feel derivative even though it's
the other way around but Star Wars
definitely is one of my all-time
all-time favorite movies let's see other
other favorite movies I could probably
think of others but those are the three
that are that are coming with a matrix
the matrix is I remember when the matrix
came out I believe it was the summer of
1998 I had just graduated from college
and everyone was excited about the new
Star Wars movies that were going to come
out the prequels that we're going to
come out at the end of that summer and
myself and a couple of friends we were
just bored one Friday and we're like
well this just movie with matrix it's
got Keanu Reeves you know maybe it's
like speed or something like that and we
went with you know fairly low
expectations but we were blown away
so I say the matrix is a pretty good
movie actually the matrix is in a
strange way it's really connected to
these notions of meditation and you know
what is reality anyway and should we get
too caught up or you know to some degree
you know every but by definition your
mind has constructed this you know the
reality now we all believe that there's
a true reality outside of our mind
that's informing our mind as we as it
constructs that reality but the matrix
definitely plays around with those ideas
I think and I end up for you in a pretty
effective way so let's see the other
other questions
so Rubik's nerd from YouTube says can
you please explain advanced quadratics
this is probably not the right place to
do it but we do have a lot of content on
advanced quadratics on Khan Academy I
would go to algebra 2 or and look at the
factoring quadratics or solving
quadratics or or solving quadratic
equations on our algebra 2 content and
maybe some of our precalculus content as
well if you're looking to advanced
quadratics so that's the best we
probably have 20 or 30 videos and
exercises just on the topic of
quadratics so I will see we're almost
out of time but I really enjoy doing
this let's see other other question so
actually is an interesting one from
Facebook Mehran ararat so hey Sal what
is your opinion about IQ intelligence
quotient I am skeptical of it I think
you can have a test with logic puzzles
and it will measure capability in that
dimension it will measure your
capability at that moment in doing logic
puzzles but well the problem I have with
intelligent IQ tests is that they'll say
they'll use that you know how you happen
to perform on those logic puzzles or
whatever they're making you do you know
at that moment and they'll make some
generalizations on your innate ability
or how that might carry over to all
walks of life and I think that just you
know you're over generalizing at that
point for example I think you could take
almost anyone and if you give them
practice solving the types of logic
puzzles that you see on IQ tests their
IQ will increase which tells you that
the IQ is not their measured IQ would
increase according to those tests
and I know plenty of people who you know
in that dimension of IQ could do very
well or might not do so well but in
other dimensions that I think any of us
would consider a sign of intelligence or
sign of critical thinking capability are
amazing you know I I know some people
who are amazing you know they're
amazingly funny or observant or you know
amazing public speakers or storytellers
which I would say in for me are is
almost the purest you know someone is
good at those things that's kind of a
raw form of intelligence but you know
because of background or exposure or
just interest have never kind of gotten
to the whole logic puzzles which tend to
show up in IQ tests so yeah you know
they're interesting I've taken them
every now and then they're fun you know
I've been one of those people who've
been lucky to be good at those things so
when I was young I remember what it was
second grade I remember you know some
kind of a psychiatrist sitting with me
for like three hours giving me a bunch
of IQ tests and then that helped me kind
of get into the school gave me more
attention which was amazing
I was lucky but you know I'm suspicious
of that test because there's other kids
that probably had at least as much
potential that probably didn't you know
that wasn't their thing so let's see
other maybe we're out of time but this
is a maybe eight are there any other
last questions that may be to finish off
in tu-tu-tu-tu-tu I'm learning actually
this is an interesting question from
YouTube a Delaine AG blip Meo says hello
Sal right now I'm learning that all the
Ivy League schools aren't requiring the
SAT what then can you enter with so at
Elaine good question so first of all if
they're making the SAT optional or the
SCT NBCT option doesn't mean that
they're not going to consider the SAT
you know I think the reason why they're
doing that especially this year is
because it's with Co vid access to some
taking some tests might be a little bit
more difficult but University of Chicago
and we had Jim nan Dorf on this homeroom
a couple of months ago
you know they famously went testing
optional but still 90% of the students
applying submit some form of SAT or ATT
scores so the university is for sure are
going to still consider it and they do
view it as something
once again they should they don't view
your SAT scores defining of who you are
but they view that in conjunction with
your grades or extracurriculars or your
your essays your recommendation as an as
something that all together can help
predict your your college readiness and
and your your long term your long term
potential so if you're if you're in a
position to take something like the SAT
highly recommend to do it now another
thing and I was talking to Jim now Dorf
about this was kind of off-camera is he
said look I would be interested in if
kids can show that they've mastered
courses on Khan Academy because not only
does that show that they've know the
material but also shows that they had
the agency and they had the the drive on
their own to learn the material and so I
highly recommend if you are thinking
about going to selective universities
get mastery at your own time based
summer is a great time to do it
especially for some of you had your
internships canceled and use that time
to master as many of the advanced
courses as you can on Khan Academy
calculus statistics physics chemistry
biology economics American history
civics these are all things that we have
at a senior or even early college level
and if you can get 90% mastery on Khan
Academy 100 percent mastery take a
screenshot and send it in with your
college application I think what
colleges will take that seriously and
also tell them why you did that because
you have Drive you have initiative
that's all the colleges are really
looking for they're looking for good
people who are interesting or want to
help the world who have the drive and
and and the intellectual capability and
the discipline to fulfill those those
ambitions at some point in their life
and also contribute to a diverse kind of
engaging community on campus so that
that's my my best advice there so we're
all out of time this is super fun we'll
do this again and thanks everyone for
joining